das heißt jemand wie Sahra Wagenknecht
ist eine bekannte Figur dann auch im
russischen sehr bekannt und er freut
sich auch einer gewissen Beliebtheit in
Russland ja mit dem gerade in dieser
Woche den den Vorwurf plötzlich im Raum
stehen sie sei von Putin bezahlt etwas
was ich sofort zurückgewiesen habe weil
ich mir das nicht vorstellen kann ich
ich kann nicht mehr sicher das ist nicht
so ist aber allein der Vorwurf der der
da plötzlich im Raum steht weil sie
offenbar jemand ist der dort gut
gelitten ist er sie ist dort in der Tat
gut gelitten sie ist natürlich keine
soll ich sagen keine populäre Figur in
Russland aber unter den
Politikern in Deutschland genießt sie in
Russland halt eben und das ist natürlich
alles durch das durch den Filter der
Propaganda sie genießt einfach sehr
große Aufmerksamkeit und es ist
erstaunlich wie viele einfache Leute in
Russland Sarah Wagenknecht tatsächlich
kennen
[Musik]